Bob Saget guys Bob Saget studio yeah
you're here nigger than that B yeah I
don't know man we got you right out of
the gate usually our big guests kind of
we like get them later on you're here
with us from the get-go I'm an additive
the gate guy this is the first sound I
make in the morning Bob thank you Chris
right now I know whatever you want to
tuck it back no just being around them
but I think that's good that's good I
feel like every man in my life I've
discovered has just like the worst
asshole and is in constantly and it's
straining if they lift weights I just
pop out and then they got a kickstand
prolapsed anus yeah oh that's a tail you
don't want it's like your vertebrae just
grew three more
[Music]
Toliver is another solid name that's the
guy goes be tied down by two-inch tall
people oh my god
Frankel you realize that would be like
Nazi nuts
that's the first thing to be affected
yeah cuz they tie him down they gotta
tie everything down yeah cuz they're
afraid he's gonna get up so he's like
thread to tie down and then he gets up
and they're all shocked and screaming
yeah that's what I was growing up just
lots of Gulliver yeah I want to be in a
boring Gulliver yeah Warner you went to
Bob Saget like woody what's your go-to
when you type in when you're hamsters
and goats not animals I'm not sure is in
front or in back that is the day
sometimes the hamster disappears they're
just in the background yeah yeah
otherwise it's just nature footage then
the go-to aid of ad can the night before
a CT shoots them out I'll be talking
faster soon I've got club soda with no
caffeine
thanks to that you don't do caffeine in
the morning I want it coffee nobody has
[Laughter]
a nice Easter yeah that's nice you don't
like Jews find them I mean I'm not you
know I'm not in mind well you know from
the old-school Italian that's how it
started in the past
I don't mind 1937 now as you quote
drawing yeah yeah
there in Brooklyn yeah yeah yeah but you
know there's air this is all fiddler
started you know they don't bother me we
don't bother them they're off the roof I
actually had a my wife celebrates Easter
in a big way which is nice what does
that mean she's she paints my eggs nice
and celebrates I picture her drawing on
your balls with like a white crayon cuz
then when you dip it in the dye you can
write on it do you guys ever do that
well actually yeah dry erase balls so
you're able to use you can use a
water-based sharpie do a map you could
find Carmen Santiago if they were
chained to the ground my solid name yeah
I'm just
I just lately I'm just Chrissy positive
I'm just trying to be positive
Chrissy positive you married a Billy
Joel yeah you know I'm just yeah I'm
just trying to stay positive with it
Bobby
Oh call me Bobby you gotta raise me and
nurse me my mom called me that but if
you're a Brooklyn guy you'll be with
there's no way I can't call you Bob and
you be my friend it's Bobby Bobby dough
sags maybe sags have sex I will call you
Bobby that's nice yeah that's probably
yeah I'm feel like a British cop so
these guys there they box what's your
what's your workout I boxed copies of my
movie Benjamin your movie Benjamin is
out on red box it is the only place to
find it though well yes right yeah but
what's happening is his it's new no
that's exciting
you're gonna you'll be famous am i
excited yeah it's a very first original
red box VOD so it means that
you can get the red box app red box just
sounds you know lascivious but it's good
good work but it is but they got 40 wins
out they got 50 million subscribers
leave it out so that's a lot of people
yeah and so I we just did a video where
I pretend that I stalked 41,000 kiosks
as a commodity but the movies about me
thinking my kids on crystal meth again
on an r-rating and there's no cursing in
it but it's a fact because it's about
drugs
it's about drugs and we say crystal meth
and and it's a drug
it's a PSA really it's a dark comedy
it's really weird like like a dark
comedy and especially one about this
issue everyone's on meth in this country
I am it teaches you that it's good to
have your teeth on hinges yeah I meet
adults that I know and trust and are
successful who've like you have done
meth before like people do met I can't
type that's just not just a legal
cannabis you know what someone's putting
in a pipe you know you have backstage
you're like let's all get high and then
someone just has something else and it's
like your whole life you would probably
go to whole life as a young Li and
you're maybe not in a relationship and
so I'm gonna hand you a drink and no one
said to you like I say to my three
daughters who are older 190 really old
but much older than me but that but you
don't take a drink from a dude either or
anybody drop they're gonna open the ring
drop this is the first I'm hearing this
thank you what sex
take novocaine before your dental work
but it's you know ladies that are out
there are dudes don't take your thing
well we smoked weed this weekend andrew
is on the road with me every weekend we
were where were we I can't literally
yesterday was in Buffalo but Saturday
nights are the MC I was like I wanted to
smoke weed it was 4/20 also I have an
addiction to it and and I go go we had
weed but no one ever everyone just gets
you a bag of weed and is very proud of
themselves where we got you the weed I
go I don't have a means to smoke this so
then I'm like can we write a bowl can we
conjure the day it's the Apple I would
have a secret dispenser punch a hole in
it take a razor break the thing off cut
your hand to shreds but you know then a
pipe hmm a long pipe to inhale right you
need then a screen of some kind to take
a piece of cloth and a rubber band and
put that on the other end of the pipe
that would go into the secrets dispenser
and on Gilligan's Island I can build a
radio out of gingers probably this was
there in the Industrial Revolution some
comics have a ball and I go they can
come back can they just give it to us
and then that seemed weird to just take
it from them and have them wait well I
didn't do you don't want it from them
have you seen their mouths Bob that is
what okay so mouth oh they all came back
I was trying to be nice and I was like
I'll just get out of one puff and then
like they'll be on their way and they
were they they were nice and everything
but we were smoking then I started
thinking like what if they have cold
sores like I've never thought about that
hey how many yeah but then I looked
around and I was like oh they seemed
fine
I never worry about that stuff I'm not
gonna start worrying about it because
once you start do it I have what do you
mean don't do it I won't do that again
stead of wax lips if you're gonna smoke
probably yeah but I like to I like to
have experiences and I don't like to be
plagued by my anxieties about I'm gonna
catch this or that I I haven't yet if I
do people live their lives being so
careful to not catch something in these
still catch it so why don't we all just
yes okay yes it's like what's really
just a name for a serious station right
because no I'm telling you you can't I
got three daughters I just tell them
kicking them nuts and run away I mean
you know well I'm not having unprotected
sex willy-nilly with local comics I'm
just sharing up if a guy's got like a
thing and you don't know he's got it and
he I do not hook up enough to catch
anything I like don't even see I haven't
seen a penis for like a really long time
every I don't look in books NatGeo
I would be terrified though like I think
then the next day if I thought that if I
had that same kind of Epiphany of like
oh like if I had unprotected sex
because guys are having uh protected sex
all the time right yes there it's crazy
how do you out in the moment you just
decide to do it and then the next day I
actually don't even count sex with a
condom as sex you know I mean Chris yeah
like if you haven't had sex in eight
months before we went on air unprotected
so so you've had yeah where the condoms
we I knew we needed unpack that because
that seemed like a multi number well
it's eight weeks eight weeks or the
woman in eight weeks but yeah it sucks a
couple days ago but was in the condom it
doesn't count protected it's not really
having sex with the rubber what in the
rubber you know you feel that's a known
thing oh the ads are you'll feel
something that's right no I well that I
can't cuz I get sore throats are you
doing it is involving your throat
because I have big tonsils I need to get
a tonsillectomy you put a condom on your
tonsil I should be putting my tonsils
but I get sore throats like for example
I like the only the last time I went
down and a girl was actually my kids mom
good just say that you can't say perform
oral sex you have to get that graphic I
mean sex
I'm not saying Eden
judges language yeah I mean I don't mind
profanity yeah but but you talk about to
make your disrespect even going down no
no no I felt like going down as pro or
worshipping exactly I'm going down I'm
saying as a man as a you know member of
the patriarchy I'm going down on a
member of the major are giving them up
as a person exactly so when I go my
points when I go down on women I would
always get sore throats and strep throat
so the last time I went down on a girl
was my kids mom on our two-year
anniversary and my friend who's my
daughter Scott's away which you're not
married to this one we're not married
but we have a three-year-old daughter
who's going to be four it was our two
year anniversary and Jennings I want to
get a hotel in this city I want you to
go down on me and I was like well you
know I get the sore throat she was like
I want you to go down at me so my best
friend who's listening to this yeah well
she's teaching Zumba right now so she's
not listening she doesn't so she so my
daughters Godfather's an emergency room
doctor so I told him I was like ill bro
listen I got to go down on my kids mom
tomorrow can you call me in a pack of
amoxicillin and he did so I went down at
her and I just he said just pop this as
soon as it's over and it's like your
morning-after pill exactly yeah tract
infection in your mouth but that's not
what I'm getting what I'm getting is
bacteria biting my nails because my
tonsils are so big and swollen
constantly there's almost an infected
she doesn't know she's very very clean
very very clean woman yes can you show
me in front just want to see pictures
clean she is please take over okay I
think there's amoxicillin
he called me an amoxicillin to work like
a charm I didn't
levaquin see you don't get pneumonia I
could be great another good name you
will not go down on them what when you
say I can't it's ruined relationships
because you expect blowjobs right sure
yeah yeah okay yeah
hurts our throat too and I'm very it's
never Lia braises our throat it's never
a mystery though I'm open about it I'm
like I tell them immediately almost the
first two things I would tell a girl on
like a dating app is that I have a
daughter and I can't go down here
because I get sore throats
those are like - opening I don't know
they should not be done in the same
paragraph those are two things that
you'll know about me within the first
few messages or minutes of a
conversation since your two years how
long ago is that that was about two
years ago now but you also I don't trust
any of these timelines because you also
told us before we went on here that you
haven't had sex in eight weeks and you
said it like you were you really meant
it like I believed you but what you
meant was you haven't had unprotected
sex which is it a thing you don't say
sex I haven't had sex when you've had
condom sex but you keep that counts
Chris I see I don't see how it counts
because it's like I'm never material as
opposed to did you miss health class a
whole year I went to Catholic school so
they don't go over this stuff Catholic
school from kindergarten all the way
through college well if you meet the
right father bill absolutely I got a lot
of things to talk about their bill
yeah there's a lot of blackouts
yeah no but where my part of Brooklyn
there was a lot of a lot of kids got hit
in my part of Brooklyn with these where
these scandals came out a lot people
were the New York Times released um all
like five hundred priests scandal like
two months ago and we were all it's a
coffee shop since Bensonhurst Brooklyn
we all had our heads down oh this
father this father this father was all
our parishes was your head down because
you were going down on someone that's
yeah but I will tell you and we all know
this it's happening everywhere all the
time and then people are going back 40
years and going you know what hell with
it I'm just gonna come out and say
what's wrong to me and it's everything
it's literally everything it's
embezzlement it's trading your kid for a
milkshake from Shake Shack
I loved that Michael Jackson
for the soul what I saw with the laugh
track did you see it with that it was so
funny they sweeten it perfectly you know
here's my joke about it which is
terrible
it's horrible cuz here's one of the
greatest artists they thought okay all
of this musics never gonna be played
again that's it's gonna be
played forever because it's just really
well produced and and and you know a lot
of little kids are that were hurt by him
will grow up and eventually come to love
his music but of but the name of his
show in Vegas is a circle de Soleil show
it's called one and I say that's his
dating range so that was the joke that
gets a quiet thing because they wasn't
talking about going down on somebody
getting infection it's the Millennial
that people like to hear sorry so
you're never gonna go down on the girls
the rest of your day I write down right
now loosely Lou I have a loose
tonsillectomy date for May 12th secta me
for your head yeah but it's three weeks
recover exactly it's recovery it's a big
problem you have to cancel a lot of
shows work narcissistic at all for work
vasectomy date you know you can do gigs
you you put frozen peas on your butt I'm
a comedian you could do my Chaplin was
one of the greatest comedians about
that's possible but yeah so it's loose
day to get your tonsils out yes so that
you can go down on girls yeah and just
stop getting strep throat and sinus
infections and all that stuff yeah but
but also plagues it's just a constant
thing yeah but I don't want to get them
out lasts a week he'll like get it out
and he won't keep to it no yeah you
don't think yeah I don't I do
do you miss it do I miss it
I guess I'd miss it there's time so the
cotton I wa I personally like porn where
the guy is eating the girl out I can I
can jerk off to that because it's not a
part of my life and yeah I I want to go
to my first show of the day yeah you're
always do you share your stuff yeah yeah
yeah I definitely do if you had any but
it's been so infrequent yeah how come
you two haven't hooked at me and him or
him but not we have yeah fine no no I go
down Arnold cause me yeah he brings me
in like a closer like yeah Dibble you
know stand in the corner and wait to eat
and you open your mouth is it almost a
penis no it looks like a butt it's like
they're almost like touching together
life just getting sick from that pretty
much pretty much you don't have to take
off seven days of the amoxicillin do you
huh you have to take all seven yeah
you're supposed why are you asking for
doctor because if he could take just one
pill he could eat ten vaginas as opposed
to ten on every vagina it's very
annoying you know what it's like one
time I took the morning-after pill and I
was like well can you come in me like
all weekend now that's how my daughter
was born the morning-after pill and I
was like I thought that it's like 72
hour block of the you know the uterus
you can't get SARS just who's dropping
loads and then BOOM okay yeah history
knows we talk about World War two all
the time
when you have your tonsils out you eat a
lot of ice can't you just go down on a
girl and then just eat a ton of ice
cream in your fine that's what yeah it
just doesn't work because yeah I got the
post nasal drip I just can't do lactose
intolerant what are you gonna do if you
have them taken out mm-hmm what are you
gonna talk about then no are you gonna
be out of material yeah well no I'm sure
something else I will talk about my
guard my gastroesophageal reflux disease
I'll talk about my you don't really talk
about eating on stage I'm starting
to talk about it now because I have to I
have to do a new hour so that's what I
talked about barb a lot of things with
me is you think I'm gonna be some type
of way because I'm this kind of guy from
Brooklyn but it's another type of thing
you people expect you to be a certain
way and then we find out you cuss and
you're dirty
stand-up movie the movie Benjamin
Benjamin comes out tomorrow on red box
and you can stream it if you are a
member of the red box it's an app it's
just an app great ensemble comedy cast
and it's a dark comedy about we don't
see many dark comedies meant to make fun
of the the whole idea of your kids you
think your kids hooked right and it's
also I guess the the byline is the first
step is admitting everyone else has a
problem yes because we are just
ill-equipped people and just laying
which most people learn yeah I've been
through a lot my family and and it
affected me because I've had a lot of
tragedy in the family and and we all
have been affected y'all knows somebody
he's got a kid or something and
something happens and you go holy crap I
can't believe it's just happening it's a
fabric of your community and your family
yeah and it changes your life and this
is a light version of that yeah everyone
everyone can relate to that and this is
a family coming together to save a kid
and realizing that they have their own
issues there yeah an intervention is
essentially people just kind of
projecting their own
phone to someone being like we're
worried about you like didn't you have
an intervention where everyone was drunk
at it or something well I got intervene
one time but just for being lazy that
was pretty much it was it wasn't a drug
thing it was just get your life together
and it was only three of my friends and
I was like this is all we can't get a
full charge of taking like a lot of
money in real estate oh that was before
that was before then I lost everything
and then I kind of gave up on everything
and then I'd adopt seek medical help did
you go to a shrink no I just stopped
drinking jger drinking yeah you're
still worried so or like a figure goes
through you like it's just it's just
Jaeger mouth butthole there's no yeah
your body doesn't serve a purpose
yeah the one thing that I think I almost
like got alcohol poisoning from and
could never drink again like I wish I
was at an intervention and the guy was
four this kid was on cocaine and
everyone's like you know we want you to
stop he's like I was doing coke with you
Tuesday you know kid right 25 or
something you got a soul number I mean
yeah I did he's in Florida yeah he's in
West Palm I did Jager I did Jager once
at a Knicks game Jager and a bunch of
vodka sodas this is all true and then
last time I ever really drank drank
drank cuz I thought I was gonna get
alcohol poisoning as well and I had sex
with a lesbian chef that night I woke up
the next morning I swear to God I woke
up the next morning she's a known
lesbian chef and and I woke up and I was
like did we have sex and she goes you
bet your ass we did I was like but I
thought you were a lesbian she was like
I have one I pick one dick a year and I
was the ticket she was making like this
unware to God she was making these
chocolate chip pancakes with his whipped
cream from scratch but I was just
throwing up Jager on her floor and I
missed my my kids Art Show guys we have
to go to break can you believe it's
already April Bob Saget is here with
this Christmas Stefano is here you don't
need a Lube if you have sex with Guy
Fieri because he's got over a year and
I'm fine I'm going to be in Nashville at
Zanies this weekend with Andrew is
opening for me yes
yes so but it's it's only the early
shows what oh you're the guy that you
don't yeah yeah yeah yeah that guy
to our relationship okay I've seen you
eat hummus witness disgusting activity
from you on a near constant basis yeah
keep you away from me it's on purpose
the best Instagram story relationship on
the Internet is so great with geometry
the geometry so know what an
obtuse angle is still do is so I know it
daddy goes down exactly on a vector yeah
vector great word it's a good name for
your kid keep talking about what I'm
starving when I get to my shows i tuck
into a plate of veggies and hummus and I
guess he witnesses some disgusting video
it's not good on his bars and then he'll
chew on is always a little wet when you
talk yeah he'll chew on his thumbs and
pull eats his own skin yet he's given me
about hummus never gone down on me
are you kidding you're not single
anymore let's talk about that you just
said like you Brett I would have a
girlfriend I had like five of them oh
you did I was divorced for 23 years and
then I finally met Kelly three years ago
and then we got married yeah five months
ago yeah she's cool as hell she's the
coolest yeah I really feel like we could
be best friends
it was through a mutual
a friend wrote Kahn in Chicago he's a
WGN guy and I just says it's a nice
person and he went yes I didn't say it
in those words and he said because it
was me 9 is what yeah hashtag he's he's
a good guy what was your first kiss what
was your first movie I don't know it was
a good kiss cuz I know what's going on
cuz we hang out as friends at first we
were in a brothel and she was a fine
work it is lay on the street with the
sign that says go down lower yourself
onto my top my life's been with a
prostitute
swear to god me neither me neither but
you didn't know right well yeah yeah I
see what you say but I never paid I've
never paid for sex I've never had a pork
chop those are two things about me never
had a pork chop and put a pork chop in
my vagina I just love I love pigs and I
love ya I live if a rat's crossing the
street or Bob Utah's haven't run or they
don't but they can affect your internal
organs there's a lot of complications
every single colectomy swollen tongue
vital organ problems literally until
right now use that in your birthing in
the back it's a little punching bag the
truth I just like that you knew his name
again father bill that was bill
nabis from Brooklyn oh yeah sure
you would say do you would say do you
have anything confess and you would say
no father bill do you want some Reese's
I like the guys combos
oh yeah combos what do you want skittles
what do you want teriyaki tender bites
yesterday on Stern they were making fun
of they get something out of these
machines that's disgusting
I like fig bars oh I think Bob Louie
likes plantain chips
[Music]
what do you want did you drink ease as a
kid risk MTV MTV like it was almost like
Celebrity Deathmatch like clip I would
chug like seven of them might jog one
you could chug them really fast no let's
watch what really watch how fast I could
check this ready it's good 17 grams of
sugar is it crazy done you can
chug these things now try some seltzer
yeah they're different here I'll get
that done an ESCO is trying to chug
Phelps it's like we knew it was just too
cold if it was warm if it was like room
temp I could have checked it you know
when you're hungover you try to chug
Diet Coke oh yeah yeah I call that the
Julie Glazer it's named after my mom
wake up early Chuck a Diet Coke do the
daily now it's like last night didn't
happen when she used Diet Coke as a
mixer
no no what was their mixer I don't know
it's just you know wit mix wine with
anything oh she's a wine for ice I don't
really know my mom would drink wine on
the ice wine on the rocks
what wine on the ice why no rice she
would though oh I don't know what the
ice does I guess it makes it more
refreshing I think everyone should be
drinking wine on the ice
it was worth it it was worth it I might
throw up mmm it would be it would be
you